how mobility
affects my business so when I started
this business just over a decade ago I
felt like I needed to have an office and
a team and a place for everybody to come
work every day
fast forward a decade I've grown my team
that 15 people sold my office and
everybody works remotely from around the
world I get as much work done on this
and on this as I do my regular computer
so when Stephen Kelly the CEO of one of
my favorite companies sage tweeted me
asking me about how I use mobility in my
company I had to make a video response
not that long ago I did a thank-you
Thursday recognizing one of the social
media managers at Sage Gregg Tirico as
well so I thought I'd share with you the
five apps that I use every day on my
tablet to improve my productivity and
how you can too the first one is Gmail
now it's not surprising to have an email
app on your tablet but I used even a
little bit differently you see I have
two folders on Gmail one folders for all
my important contacts that's my team my
family my customers media Steven if you
were to write to me you would go to that
important contact folder and I checked
those every single day from my laptop in
the morning everybody else goes to a
general folder and they only answer them
from my tablet I answered them when I'm
shopping with my wife at a mall I
answered them when I'm standing in line
at the Department of Motor Vehicles I
answer them when I'm bored and yes I
answered them even in the bathroom I
find it's a huge productivity boost for
me that I get my important emails out
every morning from my computer and then
having that general inbox everybody else
answering from my tablet my second app
is Evernote I keep a lot of the
information about my business and a lot
of the day to day tasks in Evernote it's
a great way to keep notes remind
yourself the things that you have to do
and keep on top of the activities that
are happening in your business whenever
I'm on the go and I have an idea I'm
launching a new Evernote note and I'm
writing a damn whenever I'm meeting
somebody at a coffee shop or at their
office I'm bringing my tablet and I'm
opening up an Evernote file to take
notes in our meeting that note instantly
gets synced with not only my tablet but
also my laptop and my computer so I have
access to that information anywhere that
I go I also have shared notebooks with
people on my team as a to-do list so I
can see what they're doing what's coming
up next and how
progress is and the mobile version is
great when you're traveling I'll open up
a new notebook for every city that I'm
visiting and keep track of everything
that I have to do in that city people
are meeting destinations I want to go to
restaurants I want to check out all
available at your fingertips Evernote is
free is a basic package and I'm on the
premium version which is maybe five or
ten dollars a month
my number three app is feedly feedly is
a free app that lets you aggregate your
RSS feeds so if you're a subscriber to
any blogs or news websites you can get
all of their updates through your tablet
I used to use Google Reader and I loved
Google Reader but they canceled it
Google why did you cancel that you're
killing me but luckily feedly was here
to save the day so I'll use feedly to
stay on top of my favorite blogs and
news and usually it's when I'm bored and
usually before going to bed I'll usually
pop up my tablet and read up on all the
information I miss during the day my
number 4 app is Dropbox
Dropbox is a really cool way to be able
to sync files and folders across
multiple devices so kind of like
Evernote but instead of just sharing
text files you're sharing actual big
files so for example if I had a big
presentation downtown I could make a PDF
on my computer save it to Dropbox and
then just bring my tablet with me and
loaded here and will be automatically
synced just like every node I also share
Dropbox folders with people on my team
they could drop files in there I could
drop files in there
and anytime I want to pull them up
they're available on my tablet on my
laptop or on my desktop my number 5 app
is YouTube YouTube has quickly become my
favorite place to be on social media I
like it because one the content seems to
last longer a video will last a lot
longer than a tweet or Facebook post and
I just love the audience and the
community that are on YouTube my
favorite part of my day is waking up
every day and going to my laptop and
pulling up YouTube and responding and
seeing all the comments that come in but
it's starting to get out of control I
get so many comments and I love you guys
keep commenting away I love it so much
when I'm running out of time I know
probably at some point I'll have to give
up the comments because right now I'm
responding to everybody personally if
you see a comment coming
for me it's actually coming from me so I
find that having the YouTube app on my
tablet as well gives me extra time to
respond to your comment because I love
hearing from you guys now it's a bonus
app I'm going to throw fieldrunners in
there
fueled runners is a game that my wife
has become obsessed with I almost don't
get to see this thing anymore because
she's using us so much for field runners
so if you want to make your wife happy
download the field runners game and have
fun with it but you may not see your
tablet again so that's how my business
has gone mobile Steven thank you for the
great question and congrats on running
such a fantastic business for those who
watch and I'd love to know what of the
must-have apps that you use on a regular
basis leave your favorite apps in the
comments below and if you liked this
video continue to believe and subscribe
to the channel thank you guys so much
for watching I'll see you soon sign up
for the newsletter for more believe
you